Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Das war unser Intro. Ich bin ein bisschen down irgendwie gerade. Warum denn? Ich weiß nicht, irgendwie, ich vermisse dich, dich zu sehen irgendwie. Ich auch, ich auch. Ja, irgendwie ist das eine ganz andere Situation. Wir sind nicht so beissend ironisch irgendwie, wir sind eher so aufgeladen, happy, das gefällt mir nicht irgendwie öffentlich. Ich bin sehr ironisch, ich habe eben eine Red Bull getrunken, um mich ein bisschen aufzupöchen, davor war ich sehr down. Ja, das ist mein, quasi, du kannst, ich finde, Red Bull ist ein bisschen flüssige Ironie, weil, also ich war vorher eben, war ich richtig down, so, in der U-Bahn bin ich immer down, wenn ich diese ganzen Fressen sehe. Aber bist du ironischer, wenn es dir gut geht oder ironischer, wenn es dir schlecht geht? Ich bin ironischer, wenn ich wach bin. Ja, aber jetzt gut oder schlecht.
Ich glaube, Ironie ist ja auch ein bisschen Luxus.
Also wenn es dir wirklich schlecht geht,
kannst du ja schlecht dich selbst ironisch betrachten.
Man kann nur lustig sein, wenn man eine emotionale Distanz zu dem,
was man gerade sagt, glaube ich.
Also wenn einem ein bisschen so ein Stück weit alles egal ist.
Aber die emotionale Distanz fällt dir leichter, wenn es dir gut geht.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Also denkst du, weil viele Comedians und so hört man ja so,
ja, ich wurde in der Schule gemobbt und alle machen sich über mich lustig und deswegen bin ich lustig geworden, weil die Terminienfluss bekommen haben, oder glaubst du, dass man eigentlich eher lustig ist, wenn es einem gut geht oder wenn es einem schlecht geht? Nee, ich glaube, wenn denen das egal ist, wenn die irgendwann damit abgeschlossen haben, dass alle, oder die das überkompensiert haben, so quasi so ein Schutzschild sich um sich herum aufgebaut haben, um denen mehr alles egal ist, dann, deswegen sind die lustig. Wenn Comedians erzählen, dass sie früher einmal fertig gemacht wurden, dann sind sie lustig, weil sie vielleicht, weil es ihnen irgendwann egal geworden ist. Wie hast du es denn geschafft, so lustig zu werden? Ich bin noch auf meinem Weg zum ewigen, sehr schön, sehr nett ausgedrückt. Ja, ich war letztes Mal so unsympathisch, deswegen muss ich jetzt so sympathisch antworten. Du kannst ja jetzt mal ein paar Sachen aufklären, die beim letzten Mal schiefgeglaufen sind. Weil auch ich hatte das Gefühl, dass du ein bisschen komisch rüberkommst. Warum das denn jetzt? Jetzt fehlt mir zum Beispiel die emotionale Distanz, deswegen sage ich jetzt sowas wie, wie meinst du das denn jetzt? Ich habe mit ein paar Leuten gesprochen nach der ersten Folge und es kam oft gehetzt, möchte gern lustig, möchte gern ironisch, der nächste Jan Böhmermann, Zwinker, Zwinker, da kam viel Negatives zu dir, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Oh, das ist aber gemein. Das zieht mich jetzt ein bisschen runter. Das finde ich jetzt ziemlich scheiße. Weißt du, das brauche ich noch nicht, mein Red Bull ist nämlich jetzt leer, meine flüssige Ironie ist jetzt dahin und weiss ich nicht mehr, jetzt habe ich gar keinen Bock mehr. Weisst du, wie lange haben wir jetzt aufgenommen? Zehn Sekunden.
Zwei Minuten.
Alter, ich könnte jetzt schon kotzen.
Aber nehm doch da mal zur Stellung. Also was gelobst du besser zu machen, wo hast du viel gemacht? Ich war einfach, ich habe einfach kopflos gelabert, viel zu schnell natürlich, viel zu unstrukturiert, wir haben nichts zu Ende gebracht.
Ich habe keinen Satz zu Ende gesprochen, weil im Satz eine andere Idee kam und es war einfach unerlaublich scheisse.
Aber das müssen die Leute ja nicht so sagen, die können ja mal nett sein. Was sollen die Leute mit ihrer scheiß Kritik? Was? Siehst du, aber mir geht es auch nicht anders. Viel zu schnell, überhaupt nicht schlagfertig, da geht gar nichts. Unfassbar. Damit wir heute in die Sendung mal ein bisschen Struktur reinbringen. Mir fangen jetzt an. Es tut mir leid, aber ich muss die Moderation übernehmen einfach. Du hast sie nicht an dich gerissen. Das ist, hallo, herzlich willkommen zum Podcast-Ufo, in miesen Laschlöchern. Ohne Scheiss. Ihr, die da draußen das Podcast-Ufo hört, ihr seid scheiße. Ihr seid alles miese, zynische Hater. Und ich hoffe, dass Florentin irgendwie noch eine andere Zuschauergruppe sich erschließt. Weil mit euch geht's so nicht. So, das war mein Statement. Naja, gut, das war jetzt aber mehr ein Statement als eine Moderation. Für Moderation gehört erstmal, wie heissen wir, was sind unsere Namen, was haben wir heute vor, was erwartet die Leute? Ich will jetzt auch gar nicht mit meinem richtigen Namen mehr hier die Show moderieren. Du kannst ja auch einen anderen Namen überlegen. Mein Name ist Peter Gerhard. Da hat die Ironiebombe aber wieder richtig eingeschlagen, die Kreativitätsbombe mal richtig eingeschlagen. Das ist der kreativste Name. Ich mache jetzt wieder, du musst einen Schalter umlegen können. Wenn du Profi bist, kannst du einen Schalter umlegen. Und ich lege jetzt den Schalter um. So, Leute, wir haben heute eine pickepackevolle Sendung für euch, und zwar mit zwei Themen. Das eine Thema ist, wir reden über Dinge, die wichtig scheinen, aber in Wirklichkeit überflüssig sind und wir reden über Fehlkäufe. Und wie heisst du? Ich bin der Peter. Und wie heisst ich? Florian. Ja, vielen Dank. Wir haben einiges gelernt aus der letzten Folge. Wir sind auch nicht mehr im selben Studium, muss man ganz ehrlich sagen. Wir sind ein transparenter Podcast, wir sind ehrlich, wir sehen der Tatsache ins Gesicht, dass ich Stefan nicht mehr ins Gesicht sehen kann. Und ich habe schon das Gefühl, dass das ein bisschen was ändert. Wenn ich dich sehe, wie du mit deinen Reäuglein mich anguckst und sagst, oh, bitte nicht kritisieren. Für mich ist es sehr gut. Ich fange doch gerade erst an, ich bin noch irgendwie nicht so drin, hör auf mich zu kritisieren. Deine Tipps, du mir in väterlicher Liebe gibst, verstehe ich als Kritik und nehme sie ungern an. Dieser Blick fehlt mir irgendwie ein bisschen. Für mich ist es super gut, dass ich dich nicht sehe, weil dann muss ich deine rollenden Augen nicht die ganze Zeit sehen. Ich muss sie jetzt hören. Und ich muss auch nicht sehen, wenn du die ganze Zeit aufs Handy guckst, wenn ich mal gerade irgendwie anfange, eine Geschichte zu erzählen. Das ist nämlich so ein Florentins-Ding, fäng dir mal an, aufs Handy zu gucken, wenn ich irgendwie meine Geschichte anfange. Und das merkt man nämlich, glaube ich, als Zuhörer, dass du angepisst bist von mir, und deswegen mögen die Leute mich nicht. Also, fangen wir doch gleich mal an mit der ersten Rubrik, oder? Haben wir das für einen Einspieler? Nein. Nein, okay, gut. Dinge, die wichtig scheinen, aber in Wirklichkeit überflüssig sind. Ach so, mit der willst du anfangen. Okay, dann fang doch mal an. Wir haben ja letztes Mal irgendwo angerufen. Wollen wir die Entstehungsgeschichte sagen oder sind wir da doch nicht so transparent? Ja, auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall. Dann erzähl doch mal. Nee, das war doch deine Geschichte, deine tolle Geschichte. Also wir haben letztes Mal bei der Massagesessel-Hotline angerufen, können wir heute wieder mal machen, einen lustigen Anruf, uns weiterbilden und die Welt da draußen einfach mal nutzen, die uns zur Verfügung steht. Und zwar habe ich da angerufen und die nette Dame wollte mich zurückrufen und ich habe ihr meine Handynummer gegeben, allerdings eine falsche Handynummer. Und wenige Minuten darauf klingelte tatsächlich mein Handy. Ich wurde angerufen von dieser Firma. Ich habe mich gefragt, wie das geht, obwohl ich die falsche Handynummer gegeben habe. Das heißt, Handynummern scheinen eigentlich sehr wichtig, gerade wenn es darum geht, eine Person kontaktieren zu wollen. Um sie zu kontaktieren, brauche ich die Handynummer. Ist so die allgemeine Fehlvorstellung, so die allgemeine Verwirrung, die in vielen Deutschen vorliegt, stimmt nicht, es geht auch ohne die richtige Handynummer, es klappt. Das ist interessant, echt. Du hast aber nur die Vorwahl hast du eine andere angegeben, du hast quasi 0177 gesagt, obwohl du nur ein 7-8 hast oder so, oder anders. Sowas in der Richtung, ich möchte jetzt nicht so genau ins Detail gehen, aber sowas geht, ja. Das ist krass. Ich hätte ja gedacht, das ist sehr wichtig zum Beispiel. Ja, nee, aber manchmal ist es ja oft so, dass man ja viel gelernt hat in seiner Jugend und durch Werbung und so und hat man das Gefühl, Dinge sind sehr wichtig. Aber eigentlich ist das nur eine Blase, die irgendwie aufrechterhalten wird, aber der aufgeklärte Mensch kann es auch schaffen, die zum Platz zu bringen. Hammer. Was ist dein erster Platz, deine erste Platzierung? Wir haben uns fünf ausgesucht jeweils, aber ich habe keine fünf. Ja gut, ich weiß nicht, ob das so fünf ist. Also meine erste... Du hast die ganze Zeit so einen Druck gemacht. Es müssen fünf sein. Nein, um jetzt mal... Und weh, du hast keine fünf, fange ich nicht an. Und jetzt hast du selber keine fünf. Um jetzt mal zum Konne zu kommen, da habe ich auch gleich die erste Anekdote. Dinge, die wichtig erscheinen, aber gar nicht wichtig sind. Bei mir auf Platz fünf, Sicherheit und Sauberheit. Sauberkeit. Sauberheit. Ich habe erstmal eine Doppelnummer genommen. Auf Nummer fünf ist bei mir Sicherheit und Sauberkeit. Lernt man ja von jung auf, Kind, dein Zimmer muss sauber sein, das ist wichtig, aber irgendwann im Erwachsenenalter merkt man, es ist scheißegal, wie dein Zimmer aussieht und es macht sogar mehr Spaß, in einem Tracking zu leben. Aber dazu habe ich eine Anekdote und zwar, bin ich letztens nach Hause gekommen. Spürst du mein Augenrollen eigentlich? Ich spüre es im Wackeln, ja. Ich bin nach Hause gekommen. Möchte gern witzig. Ich kann dir gar nicht zuhören. Warum denn nicht? Ne, doch, erzähl erst mal. Du kommst nach Hause? Ich komme nach Hause, genau, lege meine Kleidung ab und so. Wie klang das? Das klang so Sehr gut. Und dann lege ich meine Kleidung ab, komplett, ziehe mich komplett aus, gehe nackt in mein dreckiges Zimmer. Stolperst über die bewusstlose Frau in deinem Flur. Richtig, ach, immer noch da. Dann klingelt mein Handy, unbekannte Nummer, aha, ich gehe ran. Ein älterer Mann mit tiefer Stimme meldet sich. Ja, guten Tag. Sie kennen mich nicht und ich wollte mich nur kurz bei Ihnen melden. Sie sind ja gerade in Ihr Haus gegangen. Ja, ich habe Sie gerade gesehen, wie Sie in Ihr Haus reingegangen sind. Und Ihnen ist vielleicht nicht bewusst, was da gerade passiert ist vor Ihrer Wohnungstür. Nee, keine Ahnung. Ja, ich habe gerufen, aber Sie haben mich anscheinend nicht gehört. Okay, ja. Ja, also mein Sohn hat dann die Telefonnummer recherchiert, ihre Telefonnummer. Okay, ja, warum nicht? Ja, und zwar da links von ihrem Hauseingang, da habe ich ein paar Jugendliche gesehen, wie die sich gerade mit einer Sprühdose an der Wand zu schaffen gemacht haben. Oh. Okay, ja, bin ich gerade noch mal richtig gekommen, habe gehupt und gerufen und dann sind sie weggerannt. Also wollte ich ihnen nur mitteilen. Die werden in nächster Zeit wahrscheinlich wiederkommen. Und es hat sich herausgestellt, dass es waren Maler, die die Wand mal ansprechen wollten und die jetzt nie wiederkommen. Das war es im Grunde nicht nur so, okay, ja, sorry, so, ja, keine Ahnung. Und also dann habe ich ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht, über diesen Anruf. Ein paar Dinge sind mir aufgefallen. Erstens, ich habe nichts gefunden, ich habe mich da umgeguckt an der Wand, er hat mir relativ genau beschrieben, wo das war.
Und zweitens, woher zur Hölle hat er meine Handynummer?
Du kannst doch nicht jemanden beobachten, wie der in ein Haus reingeht und an diesen
Informationen eine Handynummer rausfinden.
Hast du wieder eine Handynummer getanzt?
Das ist doch völlig unmöglich.
Also wenn du die Hausnummer von jemandem weisst, das hilft dir doch überhaupt nicht.
Also ich meine, ich weiß nicht, was es für Hacker-Datenbanken da draußen im Internet gibt, aber eine Handynummer zu finden und vor allem dann... Das ist wuselig vor allem. Er wusste ja dann mal eine Hausnummer, wenn er generell, da leben ja mehr Leute, nicht nur ich, generell da mal angerufen hätte und gesagt hat, hier vor ihrer Wohnung gibt es Jugendbanden. Er hat explizit das Wort Jugendbanden benutzt, was mich noch sehr erfreut hat irgendwie, weil ich dieses Wort schon lange nicht mehr gehört habe. Irgendwie auf so ein Revival, Comeback der Jugendbanden freue. Wobei ich eigentlich dachte immer, ich wäre in der coolsten Jugendbande Berlins, aber das ist anscheinend nicht mehr. Nein, du bist in der Gilde, das ist was anderes. Auf jeden Fall hat mich das echt irritiert und ich konnte mir keinen Reim darauf machen, wie zur Hölle da auf meine Handynummer gekommen ist. Der hat gesagt, er saß in einem Auto vor meinem Haus und hat die gesehen und hat dann gehupt und dann sind die weggelaufen. Aber sehr strange, könnte auch ein Prank gewesen sein. Weißt du was, anscheinend ist die Nummer ja eh egal, wie wir letzte Woche festgestellt haben. Ja, tatsächlich, sie scheint wichtig. Ich glaube, der Wille zählt lang, ich glaube, der Wille zählt, weil er wollte anrufen. Und es hat auch geklappt, ja. Ich glaube, wirklich, der letzte Mal, der wollte uns auch zurückrufen, wir haben die falsche Nummer gehabt, aber der Wille zählt. Es ist glaube ich scheissegal, die Nummer ist kackegal. Ich meine, zur Not kann man die Nummer auch einfach erraten. Das ist jetzt auch nicht so schwer, da rufst du ein paar Leute an. Habe ich mir auch überlegt, so eine Telefonvermittlung, die ein bisschen günstiger ist als andere, aber dafür rät sie die Nummern, hat leider keine Datenbank, sondern sie rät halt für dich und sie ist sehr gut im Raten. Ich finde das, was er gemacht hat, auch viel creepy, creepiger als das, was die Jungs da gemacht haben. Ja, total. Man hat halt diesen jugendlichen Drang, Wände zu bemalen, sein Revier zu markieren und so, aber dass man da irgendwo anruft und Leute beobachtet, die irgendwo in ein Haus gehen, das ist total strange.
Da fängt der Creep an.
Ja, vor allem, also ich meine, ich bin ja eigentlich ein Freund von guter Nachbarschaft und nachbarlicher Liebe, also naja, vom Prinzip her, aber dieser Bürgerwehrgedanke fand ich dann schon irgendwie sau creepy, so, wir müssen zusammenhalten gegen die Kriminellen in der Stadt und so und wir solidarisieren uns jetzt untereinander, weil wir dürfen nicht untergehen und so. Das ist so dieser Pegida-Sprech, wo ich gleich so, oh, oh, oh, oh, Leute, ich bin kein besorgter Anwohner, ich bin auf gar keinen Fall besorgt, egal was passiert, ich bin nicht besorgt, nur dass es klar ist. Aber gut, dass er von Jugendbannen spricht, das finde ich auch toll. Rise of the Jugendbannen. Ja, vor allem Jugendbannen, einfach mal direkt im Plural. Also ganz, ganz strange. Ich kann, vor allem, er hat ja gesagt, mein Sohn hat ihre Nummer recherchiert. Und das, also vor allem saß dann der Sohn mit ihm im Auto und sie haben dann, also ganz, ganz komisch. Aber auf jeden Fall. Das ist vielleicht so eine Detektivfamilie, die so auch zu Hause so einen Stadtplan hängen hat, wo sie ganz viele rote Bereiche markiert hat. Und mit roten Fäden. Genau, genau. Die roten Fäden und die Bilder rausgehoben wurden. Ganz strange, also bei mir auf Platz fünf der überbewerteten Dinge sind Sicherheit, weil wer braucht Sicherheit eigentlich, das ist eigentlich Quatsch, und Sauberkeit. Einfach unbegründet, da immer im Raum stehen lassen. Vor allem tatsächlich, ich hatte ein paar Tage davor auf irgendeinem Berlin-Blog oder whatever, ich lese ja Berlin-Blogs, um cooler zu sein, stand das Zitat, Berlin ohne Graffiti ist München.
Habe ich auch gelesen heute.
Ja, genau.
Nein-Gag kann man da ruhig zu ruhig sagen.
Ja, aber ist das wirklich Nein-Gag?
Ich habe es irgendwo auf so einer Seite gesehen.
Aber auf Nein-Gag kommt es keine Berlin-Gag, das ist eine internationale Seite.
Aber egal, auf jeden Fall habe ich mir sogar fast überlegt, ob ich ihm das Zitat hätte sagen sollen, so, ja, passen auf, das sind Jugendbanden, die sparen, dann habe ich ganz cool, ohne Graffiti ist Berlin-München. Geil, vielleicht hat er dann mit seinem Sohn demnächst Leute angerufen, die nicht Häuserwände markieren. Genau, finde ich einfach ganz cool, irgendwie so darauf stolz zu sein, dass Kriminalität in der Stadt herrscht. Da wurde jemand erschossen am Potsdamer Platz ohne Morde. Ja und Berlin ohne Tod ist München. Genau ja sowas. Berlin ohne Mord ist Stuttgart. Ja, das ist ganz cool. Keine Ahnung, was das bedeutet. Ist Bocholt. Ich fühle mich aber auch überhaupt nicht als Berliner, von daher kann ich sowas eigentlich auch nicht sagen. Nein, fühlst du echt nicht? Nein, ich bin kein Berliner, möchte ich hier mal sagen. So, Platz fünf bei dir. Sagen wir mal Platz drei. Wir müssen das aber jetzt auch nicht so hart durchexerzieren, oder? Wir können auch schon ein bisschen jumpen, ein bisschen hin und her. Einfach mal so moderativ jumpen, Überleitungen machen und so. Bei mir ist CD-Laufwerk auf fünf oder vier oder drei. Aber wirken für mich jetzt nicht wichtig auf den ersten Blick. Doch, ohne Scheiss. Ich dachte, das wäre ultra wichtig. Ich habe ja auch mich damals mal nach einem neuen Laptop umgeguckt und dachte immer, oh fuck, die haben alle kein CD-Laufwerk mehr, die neuen, und dachte, das ist ein Verlust, wo man wirklich einen Einschnitt in seinem Leben hinnehmen muss bei einem Kauf.
Aber es ist nicht so. Man lädt nur noch runter.
Das ist eigentlich egal. CDs sind eigentlich egal.
Das ist meine Anekdote.
Das ist alles, alles soll ich dazu sagen.
Aber fängst du an, die Kritik zu verstehen, die Leute an dir äussern?
Nein. Langsam. Aber ich versuche, lustig zu sein in diesem Moment gerade. Es ist einfach, so ein Downer war das. Es ist mir leid. Es ist mir nicht traurig. Nein, aber du musst dich doch gegen die Kritik behaupten. Kritik ist doch Witz. Nee, aber sie haben ja recht. Die Leute haben ja recht. Was soll ich dazu sagen? Das ist ja der Schlimmste. Ach ja. CD-Laufwerk ist bei mir auf Weisendicht. CD-Laufwerk ist ein echter Downer, Stefan, ohne Witz. CD-Laufwerk ist ein echter Downer. Ich habe eben diese Liste gemacht, weil ich eben gerade mal Zeit hatte, mich für diesen Kack hier, für diesen ungeliebten Scheiss-Podcast. Okay, aber gut, nee, nee, nee, dann ziehen wir es durch. Dann musst du jetzt deine Suppe ausläufeln. Dann stelle ich dir jetzt eine Frage, hattest du schon mal ein externes CD-Laufwerk? Zack, jetzt meine Frage. Ja, habe ich ja jetzt, habe ich jetzt, aber es war Fehlkauf. Ah, zweite Liste, die wir heute machen. Fehlkäufe, ja, das CD-Laufwerk war ein scheiß Fehlkauf, weil man braucht einfach keine mehr. Jetzt hat man keine Laptops, also jetzt haben die Laptops keine CD-Laufwerke mehr, deswegen kauft man sich externe CD-Laufwerke und dann fällt einem auf, es hat einen Grund, warum Laptops keine CD-Laufwerke mehr haben, man braucht sie einfach nicht mehr. Ich habe tatsächlich noch eine riesige DVD-Sammlung und kann die mittlerweile auch nicht mehr anschauen, weil bei meinem stationären Rechner ist das Laufwerk kaputt gegangen, mein Laptop hat keins, von daher kann ich die eigentlich wegwerfen, ist auch überbewertet. Zum Thema Fehlkäufe, du bist ja berüchtigt für Fehlkäufe. Unfassbar.
Ich glaube, ich habe nie jemanden in so kurzer Zeit kennengelernt, der so viele falsche Käufe getätigt hat.
Weil ich so anfällig bin, ich bin so anfällig für Werbung.
Ich nenne einfach mal ein Beispiel, betrocknete Mango, ja, das war für mich, glaube ich, der erste Fehlkauf, den ich bei dir so beobachtet habe. Wir gehen irgendwie einkaufen, Haar, Lebkuchen, die Kinder strömen aus und bringen feine Schokoladen, Nüsse, tolle Kernen, Brot, Speck, tolle Sachen zaubern sie hervor aus den Regalen. Und Stefan steht mit skeptischem Blick vor den getrockneten Mangos und soll ich meine 1,20 Taschengeld nicht dafür ausgeben? Und alle sagen, nein, auf gar keinen Fall. Alle haben davon abgeraten, wer hat mir abgeraten? Die Frage stellt sich nicht, du willst keine getrockneten Mangos kaufen, aber Stefan, nee, ich kaufe die jetzt, das muss sein. Und er hat sich tatsächlich mitgebracht. Ich dachte am Anfang, wenn man sich vielleicht geschmacklich an sowas gewöhnt, dann hat man immer was, was garantiert noch im Regal vorhanden ist, weil es kein anderer kauft. Das war die Idee dahinter. Das ist ganz gut, ja. Aber es schmeckt einfach scheiße. Und es war wirklich nicht gut. Und der ganze Raum hat danach gestunken. Aber am Ende haben es doch alle gegessen, weil es das einzige war, was noch im Raum über war. Das stimmt, ja. Aber gut, aber das ist auch nicht so positiv, wenn man das isst, statt zu verrunken. Nein, das ist absolut negativ. Das war auch ein richtiger Fehlkauf. Ich stehe mir meine Fehlkäufe aber auch gut ein, weil ich bin sehr anfällig für Werbung und habe immer so kurze Interessensphase. Aber da war nicht mal Werbung, diese Mangoschnitten wurden nicht mehr beworben. Ja, aber das Etikett war schön, was weiß ich. Das war überhaupt nicht so ein scheiß Bio, furchtbares Etikett. Aber die sahen halt gut aus. Aber die gefiel halt der Gedanke. Der Gedanke, Mangos zu essen, gefiel mir ganz gut in dem Moment. Es klingt halt exotisch, was exotisches hat man nicht alle Tage. Das stimmt, war ein riesen Fehlkauf, habeabe ich ganz vergessen. Bei meinen Fehlkäufen geht das manchmal unter. Was steht denn auf deinen Fehlkäufen? Oder soll ich mal anfangen? Bei mir steht zum Beispiel drin Portemonnaie. Auch Classic, ein Classic. Ich habe mir neulich ein Portemonnaie gekauft. Kennt ihr vielleicht, bei Facebook kommt manchmal diese Werbung, da gibt es ein neues Portemonnaie, das ist super slim und nie wieder dickes Portemonnaie.
Aber es ist wahnsinnig schön gemalt und wahnsinnig schön illustriert. Aber jeder, der diese Werbung sieht, denkt doch, ja gut, dafür brauche ich jetzt kein extra Portemonnaie, ich tue halt einfach weniger Zeug in mein vorhandenes Portemonnaie. So, das sind die Normalo, das ist das Mainstream-Denken. Das sind die Leute, mit denen du dich gerade hier wieder, Stichwort Populismus, verbrügern willst. Aber das ist so, wenn du irgendwie bewirbst, ich verkaufe einen Kofferraum, der ist besonders aufgeräumt.
Da denkst du ja auch, ja gut, dann kann ich eigentlich den Kofferraum, den ich schon habe, einfach aufräumen. Das ist ja keine Dienstleistung. Ja, aber es ist halt ein Startup und so und hat all diese Startup-Mentalität in dem Facebook-Kosmos versprüht. Und dann dachte ich mir, komm, wie unterstützt du mit 59 Euro? Fühlen Scheiß. Da ist dein Geldbeutel auf jeden Fall dünner. Knick, knack. Oh yeah, Gagmode on. Oh ja. Nee, es ist wirklich so, es ist wahnsinnig scheiße das Portemonnaie. Ich würde von allen, wenn ihr diese Werbung seht, dann klickt oben auf Werbung melden oder so. Es wäre so schön, wenn wir jetzt in einem Raum wären, weil ich würde es mir gerne noch mal in Detail anschauen, weil man hat sich ja schon ein bisschen was gedacht, das ist ja kein Portemonnaie
wie das andere ist. Du hast es mir gezeigt und ich dachte mir
schon, oh, da hat sich jemand Gedanken gemacht,
zwar die falschen Gedanken, aber gewisse Gedanken
sind in dieses Produkt geflossen, wie zum
Beispiel das Fehlen
der Münzgeldtasche. Ja,
die haben halt geschrieben, sie haben durch jahrelange
Forschung und Studien
rausgegeben. Münzen sind sehr schwer und sehr dick.
Forschung und Studien catcht mich, egal wer was, wenn McDonalds das schreibt, ich gehe sofort hin und kauf alles, was die haben. Irgendwann haben die dann geschrieben, ja, sie haben ja herausgefunden, wie man Portemonnaies statistisch dünner bekommt. Aber die haben nicht dabei geschrieben, dass sie einfach versuchen, die dünner zu bekommen, indem man einfach das Geld... Die weglässt. Genau, einfach das Münzfach weglässt komplett. Na klar, aber jedes Scheissportemonnaie ist halt flacher, wenn man das Münzfach weglegt. Aber was ist das für ein Konzept? Du kannst doch einfach keine Münzen in der Portemonnaie tun. Ja, natürlich, aber das schreiben die ja nicht so. Die schreiben das dann so wunderschön und diese Star-Denheit. Aber allein dieses Konzept ist doch schon so dämlich, da muss man doch sofort sehen. Das ist wahnsinnig dämlich. Das kann nicht funktionieren. Dünnheit ist doch kein extra Feature, für das man Geld verlangen kann. Nicht bei einem Gegenstand, den man selbst befüllt, wo man selbst die Dicke entscheidet. Das ist wahnsinnig schade. Das kann doch nicht sein. Du kannst auch eine besonders leere Tasche verkaufen. Aber da kann man auch sagen, ja, ich kann auch die Sachen, die ich schon habe, einfach aus meiner Tasche tun. Da habe ich auch eine leere Tasche. Riesenfehlkauf, ich weiß. Riesenfehlkauf. Naja, aber die haben ja gesagt, das ist wahnsinnig dünn und so und die Karten kann man hier und da reinstecken und dadurch spart man halt Platz. Man will ja auch ein dünnes Portemonnaie haben, ist ja auch ein Ziel, was man sich gut setzen kann in meinem Leben. Ein dünnes Portemonnaie ist ein gutes Lebensziel, finde ich. Und das dachte ich mir auch bei dem Kauf. Ach, geht so. Ach Gott, das war wirklich schlau. Aber da habe ich jetzt echt mal eine Frage und eine generelle Frage auch an die Zuhörer. Die können jetzt mal ganz kurz zuhören. Leute, kurz aufwachen.
Halt mal kurz auf zu onanieren.
Halt mal kurz auf. Und zwar frage ich mich schon seit langem, wie Leute mit Kleingeld umgehen. Ich sage dir ganz kurz, wie ich mit Kleingeld umgehe. Ich gehe durch den Tag, kaufe mir hier und da getrocknetes Obst. So in etwa gehe ich durch den Tag, hallo, guten Tag, Herr Postbote, ha ha ha, netter Hund, streichle ich kurz, vor Locken pfeifen gehe ich durch die Strassen, ah, hier möchten Sie Zimt kaufen, ja, kaufe ich, hier möchten Sie Bananen, ja, nehme ich, kaufe im Verlauf des Tages verschiedene Dinge. Und am Ende des Tages habe ich Kleingeld. Dann gehe ich schlafen, schlafe ein wenig, dann stehe ich auf, mache mich bereit für den nächsten Tag und dann kontrolliere ich mein Portemonnaie und schmeisse alles Kleingeld, was ich habe, in einen Eimer. Ich habe einen Plastikeimer hier stehen und da schmeiße ich das Geld rein, so dass ich am Anfang des Tages ohne Kleingeld das Haus verlasse, damit mein Portemonnaie dünn ist. Und wie dünn ist es dann ohne Münze? Sehr dünn, sehr dünn. Ungefähr 20 Kreditkarten, einen Haufen Rechnungen, irgendwelche unnützen Sachen und tatsächlich, eigentlich ist Portemonnaie ein eigenes Thema. Ist eine Show wert, finde ich. Ist eine Show wert. Ich hänge es mal hinten an, weil ich habe noch was zu Portemonnaie zu sagen. Aber, und so kommt es, dass ich eigentlich nie Kleingeld habe. Aber wie gehst du denn mit Kleingeld um? Weil wenn du jetzt so ein 5-Cent-Stück in deinem Portemonnaie hast, das kriegst du ja nicht mehr los. Ich sammle es. Ich sammle es einfach, weil ich mich schlecht auch von Dingen trennen kann wieder. Ich aber auch. Das ist ein total gutes Gefühl, so viel Kleingeld zu haben. Es ist irgendwie auch, ja, es ist ein bisschen creepy auch, aber ich habe so einen Briefumschlag, wo das ganze Kleingeld reinwandert. Der ist sehr schön voll. Briefumschlag? Ja, ich hätte halt nichts anderes. Ich bin halt umgezogen, da hat man halt keinen
Eimer gerade rumstehen und will sich auch keinen kaufen, deswegen habe ich so einen Briefumschlag,
wo ich alles Kleingeld reinmache. Ist wahnsinnig überfüllt schon. Warte, Leute, Leute,
ein Riesenfehlkauf. Hört euch das jetzt mal an und sagt mir, dass ihr keine Gänsehaut bekommt.
Was ist das? Was ist das? Luftpolsterfolie. Nein, das ist mein Kleingeld. Ach so. So schlecht verstehe ich, was du machst gerade. Ja, aber du hast einen Umschlag oder was? Das ist das Bescheuerste, was ich in meinem Leben gehört habe. Es ist nur provisorisch. Es ist nur provisorisch. Und es passt ja auch so viel Geld in meine Portemonnaie. Manche Leute haben eben nicht, weil du kein Münzgeldfach hast. Manche Leute, ganz kurz, manche Leute haben Sparschwein oder geben es irgendwie Obdachlosen oder zahlen es an und du hast einen Umschlag. Ja, ich wünsche mir zu Weihnachten von dir wünsche ich mir einen Sparschwein oder einen Eimer. Irgendwas, wo ich mein Kleingeld... Irgendwo, wo ich mein Kleingeld... Oh, es ist traurig, es ist einfach nur traurig, ich führe ein trauriges Leben hier. Und die Podcast-Ufo-Hörer machen mir auch noch fertig, die fünf, die wir haben. Das ist echt traurig. Ne, das ist wirklich ein bisschen Provisorium, aber du kannst mir ja zu Weihnachten kannst du mir ja ein Sparschwein schenken. Von allen Gegenständen der Welt ein Briefumschlag, unfassbar. Ich gehe mal zu einem Fehlkauf von mir. Ich würde sagen, wir machen da keine Liste, weil ich nicht so viele habe, und zwar ein Fehlkauf von mir... Da habe ich sehr viele. Mehr als zehn. Ein Fehlkauf von mir ist jede Pflanze, die ich je gekauft habe. Ja, und ich habe auch mal einen Kuss noch dazu. Aber total! jede Pflanze, die ich je gekauft habe. Ja, aber total. Jede Pflanze, die ich je gekauft habe, bis in halb von 20 bis 30 Minuten gestorben, tot, ich habe entweder viel zu viel Wasser, kein Wasser oder zu wenig Wasser oder andere Flüssigkeiten reingetan und sich denkt, naja gut, wenn es Wasser mag, mag es auch Cola, ja, rein, tot, jede Pflanze, aber ich bin so dumm und kaufe mir immer wieder neue Pflanzen, weil ich einfach diese Vorstellung mag, dass ich jemand bin, der Pflanzen hat, irgendwie grün und CO2 ist ja ganz nett und so und will man ja haben und die sehen dann schön aus und wachsen, aber die gehen alle drauf, das ist wirklich Knochenmühle, Florentin Wills Wohnung, da geht alles drauf, wahrscheinlich so im im Baumarkt so, was, Florentin Will hat mich gekauft, fuck, da gehen alle sofort drauf. Das ist bei mir auch so. Ich hatte mal eine Phase, da hatte ich sehr viele Fliegen in der Wohnung, ach, weiss ich auch nicht warum, so kleine Obstfliegen. Wo wohnst du, ohne Witz, wohnst du in Narnia, du wohnst echt in so einem Abenteuerland, du hast ganz strange Sachen, Du schläfst, wahrscheinlich schläfst du in der Hängematte und irgendwie dein Boden ist irgendwie Gitter und du hangelst dich über die Decke und dein Kleinkind ist in der Wohnung. Ich hatte hier Fruchtfliegen in der Wohnung, weil ich irgendwie, weiß nicht, so Obst halb habe stehen lassen und dann haben sich im Sommer halt diese Fruchtfliegen gebildet und das werden ja unfassbar viele. Und dann habe ich mir fleischfressende Pflanzen zugelegt. Pflanzen, plural. Ja, gleich mehrere. Und es war allen ein Fehlkauf, jeder einzelne war ein Fehlkauf, es existiert keine mehr. Beziehungsweise eine steht noch irgendwo rum, aber es ist schon schwarz mittlerweile. Und wenn normale Pflanzen kaputt gehen, dann ist es ja nicht so schlimm, als wenn fleischfressende Pflanzen, die haben noch so eine Vitalität die haben so, die schreien noch so eine Vitalität aus irgendwie,
als ob die wirklich, weil die machen ja auch dann Mund zu und so und sie haben so, sie sehen aus wie ein Gesichter, also in meiner Welt, oh man. Bist du dir sicher, dass du da Pflanzen gekauft hast? Ja, ich glaube schon. Irgendwie Tamagotchi oder so. Pflanzen war sehr hässlicher Hamster, ich weiß nicht. Aber ich finde es so lustig, da könnte man echt so einen Sketch draus machen, dass du immer neue Dinge kaufst, um einer Plage Herr zu werden und dann wird das wieder die neue Plage. Überall, hier ist überall Kleingeld und Fleischspassende Pflanzen, die ganze Wohnung ist... Dann musst du, ich habe mir jetzt fünf Tauben gekauft, die sollen die Pflanzen kaputt machen und dann geht das immer so weiter und am Ende hast du einen Tiger in deiner Wohnung und ich kriege diese scheiß Tiger nicht auf. Und die pflanzen sich vor wie scheiße und die haben immer die Tiger rumliegen. Kleingeld und Tiger und fleischpressende Pflanzen, die Reste noch. Zum Glück ist ein Kleingeld sicher verwahrt in den Briefum geschlagen. Gott sei Dank. Nee, und dann, ich habe am Anfang mir, als ich hier eingezogen bin, habe ich mir zwei grössere Pflanzen gekauft. Und die leben beide noch, weil es ist nämlich Pflanzen-Darwinismus. Aber es ist ja wirklich relativ random, wie viel Wasser die brauchen. Ich finde es voll. Also sagen wir mal, wenn man sich so Menschen anschaut, egal wo der herkommt, egal wie alt ist, man hat irgendwie ein Verständnis davon, wie viel Essen der braucht. Ja, genau. Und das ist auch bei allen Menschen ungefähr gleich. Also natürlich gibt es Schwankungen, irgendwie schwangere Leute brauchen mehr oder so ein Kram oder sowas. Aber bei Pflanzen ist es so unterschiedlich. Eine Pflanze braucht einmal im Monat nur irgendwie Kaktus, eine andere Pflanze jeden Tag, eine andere Pflanze so. Das ist so strange. Und auch bei einer Pflanzenart ist es random, habe ich ein Gefühl. Ja, aber es ist wirklich komplett willkürlich. Das wurde einfach ausgewürfelt im Baumarkt, als man denen mitgegeben hat. Einfach, ja, sechsmal am Tag, keine Ahnung, mir egal. Nie. Irgend so ein Kram. Und die beiden Pflanzen, die man nie gießen muss, die überleben bei mir.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass vielleicht der Vermieter aus Mitleid noch einen Wohnungschlüssel hat machen lassen, um dann meine Pflanzen zu gießen.
Irgendwie sowas muss es sein.
Weil ich weiß nicht, warum die überleben.
Fällt mir noch eine Anekdote ein.
Ja, und bitte, hau raus.
Ich kann mich aber nicht mehr hundertprozentig genau an die Anekdote erinnern.
Ich erkläre sie so, wie es in Erinnerung ist. Und falls sie nicht stimmt, sehen sie es halt einfach als improvisierten Gag an oder als Witz oder sowas. Auf jeden Fall, ich glaube, Freunde meines Mitbewohners hatten eine Wohnung und haben da relativ lange zu zweit gewohnt und irgendwie ist ihnen immer aufgefallen, dass Sachen verschwinden. Irgendwie Kleingeld vom Tresen irgendwie lag da aus dem Briefumschlag, die Briefe verschwinden hier und da und Essen ist irgendwie weg und wusste nicht genau, was da passiert. Das muss eine wahnsinnig ganze Geschichte sein. Aber einfach die Forscher und irgendwie da lagen auch so Krümel rum und so und sie dachten schon, sind da Ratten oder was? Oder haben wir irgendwelche Tiere im Haus?
Und sie hat, und raus kam, sie haben einen dritten Mitbewohner, dich, und du bist bis dahin noch nie aufgefallen.
Und auf jeden Fall kam dann raus, dass ihr Vormieter immer noch den Schlüssel zur Wohnung hat und sie tatsächlich ab und zu besucht und rausgefunden haben, indem sie eines Tages nach Hause kam und der Vormieter sß in der Wohnung und hat gegessen am Tisch, hat sich so ein Leibbrot hingestellt und Margarine und Wurst. Entschuldigung, wer sind sie? Ich wohne hier auch. Die haben sie nur noch verpasst. Die Vorstellung, dass jemand, der offensichtlich in eine fremde Wohnung einbricht, wo die Leute, man weiss, dass andere Leute es ein einfaches Bewusstsein hat, ich mache mir hier
ein paar Eier und hier ein paar Sachen, schneide mir einen schönen Apfel auf. Ich finde das so geil, einfach diese Eier, die man braucht, um das zu machen und schönen Tee und gemütlich und ich nehme Bad und alles. Also unfassbar, aber allein stell dir die Situation vor. Du kommst rein und der Typ nicht irgendwie mit der Pistole und Maske steht da. Da gibt es ja ein soziales Protokoll, wie man sich zu verhalten hat, wenn man einem Einbrecher gegenübersteht. Entweder man flieht oder man kämpft oder man ruft die Polizei. Aber so was, da gibt es ja auch kein Protokoll. Schmeißt man den dann raus oder isst man mit? Was macht man denn? Das ist eine Situation, da hat man einfach keine Vorstellung davon, was sich jetzt gehört zu tun. Also man weiss es einfach nicht. Das ist echt gut, das ist eine gute Geschichte. Die sollten wir auch vielleicht noch ein paar Mal auch noch heute erzählen. Ich werde sie lupen. Ich schneide sie raus und schneide sie so alle fünf Minuten rein. Was ich noch ganz kurz sagen wollte und was ich tatsächlich persönlich für eine extrem gute Idee halte, und da werde ich vielleicht mein eigenes Startup gründen, um diese Idee finanziell umzusetzen, und zwar trage ich tatsächlich in meinem Portemonnaie meine Schlüssel. Die würden bei mir nicht mehr reinpassen, weil es ist zwar kein Münzgeldfach, aber es hat auch keine anderen Fächer, grossartig, und es ist einfach scheiße und es ist kaputt und es passt auch kein Schlüssel mehr rein. Aber vor allem, nein, weil ich habe tatsächlich immer panische Angst, irgendwas zu vergessen. Und deswegen dachte ich mir, wenn ich einfach meine Schlüssel in meinen Geldbeutel tue, vergesse ich entweder alles oder gar nichts. Was schon mal ganz gut ist, ich gehe all in, mein Lebensmotto ist all in. Und deswegen, mein Geldbeutel hat da so am Scharnier, sag ich mal, in am Scharnier, noch so einen Reißverschluss, den man öffnen kann. Und ist da noch so eine Kammer zwischen der Decke und dem Geldfach, keine Ahnung, ob es sich das mal vorstellen kann, und da tue ich meine Schlüssel rein und habe das seit jeher gemacht, seit ich aus der Schlüssel habe und tatsächlich ist es die geilste Idee und alle Leute, die dann irgendwie so einen riesigen Klumpen Schlüssel in ihrer Hosentasche haben, da irgendwie so einen Brocken mit sich rum tragen, ich habe letztens mir mal kurz deinen Schlüssel ausgeliehen und dachte mir, ach du meine Scheiße, was ist denn da los, wie kann man denn mit so einem riesigen Bleibrocken durch die Gegend laufen, ohne an den Magneten ständig hängen zu bleiben oder sowas. So stelle ich mir die Gefahren in dem Haus eines Stefan Titze vor, der natürlich Magneten engagiert hat, weil er mit den radioaktiven Strahlen nicht mehr klarkommt, die er sich in die Wohnung geholt hat, um die gegen Mäuse zu gehen.
Nein, ist ja alles voll, ist ja alles voll von Schwärmen, die Schwärme fressen.
Genau, ja. Und ja, und deswegen, also nur so als Tipp für mein Startup geht auf www. irgendwie Kickstarter slash moneykey, walletkey, keywallet, quality, quality, ja, quality, quality, quality, quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, Quality, nicht, weil das iPhone an sich schlecht ist, sondern weil ich es direkt verloren habe. Und zwar war ich ... Also eigentlich, es liegt nicht am ... Wahrscheinlich liegt es auch nicht am Portemonnaie, sondern an mir, weil ich so dämlich bin, das nicht so fach zu finden. Ich glaube auch, dass die anderen Fehlkäufe eher an dir lagen und nicht notwendigerweise an den Produkten. Jedenfalls war es ein Beatstecks-Konzert, Beatstecks aus Berlin und die waren glaube ich in Essen oder so und dann habe ich da beim ersten Song mein Handy verloren. Das ist so scheiße. Woher weißt du, dass du es genau beim ersten Song verloren hast? Weil es direkt, man fasst sich an die Taschen und es war einfach nach dem ersten Song nicht mehr da. Es wurde geklaut. Es wurde geklaut, genau, im Nachhinein kam auch raus, es war irgendwie so eine Bande, die bei Konzerten der Beatstecks immer unterwegs waren, weil man da halt besonders im Moshpit vorne besonders gut klauen kann. Der legendäre Moshpit von den Beatsteaks. Die so legendären Moshpit-Diebe. Mir ist kein coolerer Name jetzt gerade eingefallen. Jedenfalls, das war unglaublich scheiße, weil das Portemonnaie ist weg, das Portemonnaie und Handy war sogar weg. Und beides zu verlieren ist echt scheiße, weil beides ist ein Riesendauner und du verlierst ja quasi das Konzert noch als Spaßfaktor. Eigentlich ist das der schlimmste Diebstahl, den Spaß zu nehmen. Materielle Dinge sind ersetzbar, aber ein Beats-Sex-Konzert nicht. Ich hatte so keinen Bock mehr nach dem ersten Song und dann fing es an, wenn man die Leute dann anfangen zu pogen und zu tanzen, dann wurde es bei mir aber irgendwann so Aggression, da habe ich einfach die Leute angerempelt, weil die mir auf den Sack gingen, weil die ganze Scheiße und da dachte ich mir, nein, nicht zugaben, einfach zu gehen, alle bitte, da kann ich mein Handy auf dem Boden suchen, weil es irgendwie runtergefallen ist oder so, aber es war wirklich geklaut, es war weg und das war wirklich scheiße. Mein Portemonnaie war dann am Ende noch da, es wurde irgendwie gefunden, aber da war nur noch meine Buswagate drin, die aber abgelaufen war. Alles geklaut, knallhart. Auch die Mangoschnitten, die noch drin waren. Wirklich scheiße. Mein neues Portemonnaie hingegen, der einzige Vorteil, den es hat, ist, es hat so versteckte Fächer. Da kann man dann irgendwie Rechnungen reinstecken, wo man nicht will, dass andere die sehen. Es hat so versteckte Fächer. Also kein Münzgeldfach, aber versteckte Fächer, die niemand braucht. Und da könnte ich Sachen drin verstecken, die man nicht finden würde vielleicht als Dieb. Aber mehr Vorteile hat das leider nicht. Fehlkauf. Ich muss gerade an meinen ersten MP3-Player denken. Das war der iPod Shuffle. Und zwar gab es da von Apple, als es losging mit den MP3-Players, so eine Produktlinie, so ganz billig, so ich glaube 100 Euro oder 50 Euro. Wahnsinnig billig. Die damalige Zeit sehr billig, weil das der iPod bestimmt 600 Euro gekostet hat oder Mark, keine Ahnung, Geld gekostet hat. Und zwar hatte der genauso viel Speicherplatz für ein Album, für ein Album, also für 20 Songs maximal oder sowas, und er hatte kein Display. Ach, wie scheiße. Das heißt, du konntest die Songs Ah, den kannte ich, den kannte ich, den kannte ich, den Raffel. Genau, du konntest die Songs entweder in der Reihenfolge abspielen lassen oder halt Zufallswiedergabe und hattest dafür manuelle Knöpfe, die du drücken konntest. Das ist ja geil. Aber du hast ja nicht gesehen, welche Lige du gespielt hast. Nee, das ist immer so ein bisschen Rätselraten. Aber wenn nur ein Album drauf ist, dann hast du ja auch nicht so viel Überblick zu fallen. Aber vor allem stell dir das mal vor, weisst du, da musst du wirklich dir deinen Musikgeschmack zurechtlegen und sagen, okay, ich fahre jetzt in Urlaub, Gran Canaria, vier Wochen und ich habe ein einziges Album, das ich mitnehmen kann. Ein einziges! Stell dir das mal vor, da musst du den im Vorhinein aber jeden Kilobyte perfekt ausnutzen, damit du am Ende nicht sagst, scheiße, der fabelhafte Welt der Amelie-Soundtrack war es dann doch nicht. Fuck! Oder wenn du dann so ein Problem hast, dass dir auf dem Flug klar wird, dass du das Album gar nicht magst, was dir gefällt, weil dass du deinen Geschmack geändert hast, weil plötzlich irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, im Flugzeug, im Radio was Besseres lief. Das ist ja voll scheiße. Bei mir ist ja immer so, ich habe ja die, wenn ich Bahn fahre, und ich fahre ja jede Woche nach Köln und zurück, da habe ich ja immer das Bahnticket auf meinem Handy. Das kann man dann runterladen und dann kann man das dann aktivieren über die App und dann hat man diesen QR-Code und den kann dann der Kontrolleur abscannen.
Das heißt, immer wenn der kommt, hole ich mein Handy raus und dann checkt der Kontrolleur das schon und schaut auf mein Display, weil er schon erwartet, dass da jetzt was passiert und sieht, was ich gerade höre für Musik oder sieht zumindest das Bild von dem Albumcover. Und das sind wirklich die unangenehmsten Sachen. Und ich habe einfach so ein wahnsinniges Pech dabei, wenn ich irgendwelche Spotify-Playlists, die ich mir im Vorhinein gar nicht angeschaut habe genau, kommt genau in dem Moment irgendwie Jan Thiersen, irgendwie Romantik, Kuschelrock, irgendwelche Verliebtsein-Songs, die ich alleine in der S-Bahn wie ein Obdachlose mit meiner Jacke zugedeckt mir anhöre. Das ist immer sehr unangenehm. Das ist, glaube ich, so eine ganz spezielle Form von Pech, dass man immer zur falschen Zeit das falsche Lied hört. Und dann blickt er von oben herab und lächelt dann so. Will man immer so ein Ja, gut. Also soll man da noch drauf eingehen oder macht es das noch peinlicher? Ich glaube, du kannst sogar, wenn du kein Ticket hättest, könntest du dich so überspielen, wenn du Mitleid mit dem Lied verursacht, was du gerade hörst. Absolut, ja, stimmt. Wenn du zum Beispiel den Musikgeschmack von dem Kontrolleur triffst, glaube ich, kannst du sehr viel rausholen, Sympathien. Ein guter Trick eigentlich, auch eine Kickstarter-Idee vielleicht. Ich glaube, wenn Leute unseren Podcast hören, dann denken sie gerade bei dir, das ist ein lustiger Typ, der scheint mit einer gewissen Leichtigkeit durch den Alltag zu gehen. Der hat so viele, dem passieren so viele tolle Geschichten. Wenn dem tolle Geschichten passieren, dann ist er bestimmt, hat er immer einen tollen Spruch auf den Lippen und dann ist er toll. Aber bei mir zum Beispiel ist es das totale Gegenteil. Ich erlebe zwar lustige Geschichten, bin aber, wenn ich sie erlebe, null Prozent lustig. Das denke ich mir auch immer. Aber null ist. Ja, deswegen sind Zeitmaschinen ja auch sowas unfassbar geiles, weil du mal zurückfahren könntest und die schlagfertigste Antwort ever geben könntest. Ja, absolut. Oder zumindest, sag ich mal, der Situation mit einem humoristischen Intention. Also zum Beispiel habe ich mir heute einen Burger gekauft. Und das war, also ich habe es in so einem,-Restaurant, Halb-Imbiss-Ding gekauft und da kriegt man immer so eine Art Supercomputer-Maschinen-Chip, der dann vibriert, wenn dein Essen fertig ist. So, und bei mir war es dann so, ich habe gesagt, ich hätte gerne einen Burger zu mitnehmen und dann hat er mir diesen Chip gegeben, aber dann wollte ich mich jetzt nicht hinsetzen. Jetzt sagen müssen, nein, ich wollte einen Burger. Das ist tatsächlich kein schlechter Gag, den muss er mal machen. Willst du den mal machen? Nein. Bis nächste Woche will ich, dass du den machst. Und ich will, dass du mir sagst, wie er angekommen ist. Kennst du ja bestimmt, gibt es in Köln bestimmt auch. Ich wette, verachtende Blicke werden kommen. Oder er hört ihn jeden Tag. Genau, er hört ihn jeden Tag zweimal. Weil du schon die Woche dreimal da warst, um den vor mir zu machen, auf jeden Fall. Auf jeden Fall die Frage ist, ich habe diese Maschine, diesen Chip bekommen, wollte mich aber jetzt nicht zu den normalen sitzenden Gästen hinsetzen, weil ich mit Jacke und Uffa. Weil du Florentin Will bist. Weil ich Florentin Will bin, ja. Und ich wollte mich jetzt nicht so awkward alleine an so einen grossen Tisch hinsetzen und dann warten und nichts tun. Deswegen wollte ich stehen bleiben, wusste aber nicht genau, wo ich jetzt warten soll. Soll ich irgendwie lässig an der Bar liegen oder so und habe mich dann so an eine Wand gelehnt, so ein kompletter Montur. Und dann habe ich mir auch gedacht, soll ich jetzt das Restaurant verlassen und so ein bisschen um Block gehen, aber dieser Chip hat wahrscheinlich nur eine gewisse Reichweite, dass er dann auch kontaktiert werden kann, dann kriegst du es nicht mit.
Auf jeden Fall hing ich dann so an dieser Wande und dachte mir, ja scheiße, was soll ich machen?
Und dann hat auch der Burgerbrater hinter der Theke hat mich angeschaut, so durch den Raum und hat mich einfach ausgelacht, einfach schamlos einfach.
Und ich dachte mir einfach, was für ein Arschloch!
Und im Nachhinein hätte ich eigentlich lustig reagieren sollen, aber ich habe ihm einfach nur so, ja, wo soll ich denn hingehen? So gestisch, ja, wo soll ich denn machen? So gestisch versucht, nonverbal über 30 Meter zu transportieren, was nie ankommt, aber natürlich nicht. Das ist wirklich so, aber das Leben ist halt nicht, du bist nicht schlagfertig, du bist nicht super lustig spontan. Du bist halt das einfach, ähnlichliche Leben, unfassbar scheiße und rückklingen wird es erst lustig. Aber warum kann der Typ nicht ein bisschen Empathie haben und meine Situation verstehen, dass die Situation doof ist, in der er mich getan hat, weil wo soll ich denn warten? Das ist halt einfach scheiße. Das sind so Situationen, in denen es kein soziales Protokoll gibt und da muss man improvisieren. Und dass man dabei lächerlich aussieht, ist nicht meine Schuld, sondern Schuld des sozialen Protokolls. Ich frage mich aber gerade, wie man so lächerlich aussehen kann, dass jemand über 30 Meter mit so einem Ding in der Hand, das nicht auslacht. Nur weil das die an der Wand gelegt hat und so ein Teil in der Hand gehabt. Ja, vor allem bei uns, ich kenne auch ein Restaurant, das auch solche Sachen hat und dieser Chip blinkt und vibriert, sobald dein Essen fertig ist, sodass du, dann erschrecke ich immer wahnsinnig, weil ich mich vor allem erschrecke und dann hat man sehr Geld, sein Essen. Ich wusste aber nicht, ob das bei diesem Ding auch der Fall ist, ob es auch blinkt und auch vibriert. Und du hast es die ganze Zeit angestellt und festgehalten. Oder nur eins von beiden. Und ich dachte mir, ja gut, weil ich hatte meine Winterjacke an und hatte es dann so in der Tasche und dachte mir, ja gut, wenn das jetzt nur blinkt, sehe ich das ja nicht.
Und dann habe ich das so halb vor mir gehalten, irgendwie so ganz komisch, damit ich es noch sehe, wenn es blinkt. Ich muss mich aussehen haben wie ein Depp, der einfach so komisch dieses Ding hat. Aber wie soll ich es denn sonst machen? Hast du auch in die Luft gehalten, weil du denkst, sonst hast du kein Empfang, das Gerät. Ja, genau. Und dann bist du so ein Wettsuchend, bist du rumgelaufen mit dem Gerät. Peinlich, Florentin. Was muss für mich passiert sein? Das würde jemand nämlich niemals über 30 Meter über dich lachen, glaube ich. Aber ich finde, das ist unfair in so einer Situation, wenn jemand zu lachen, wenn jemand in einer normalen Alltagssituation, wo es ein soziales Protokoll gibt, sich dumm anstellt, okay, da lache ich gerne mit, da fange ich an zu spucken und zu fluchen und zu treten, überhaupt kein Problem. Vor allem, weil der Typ ja auch augensteinig wusste, wie dieses Gerät funktioniert. Und das ist ein Open von oben herab, sitzt auf seinem Geräte-vibrierenden Elfenbeinturm und guckt auf dich herab, wie du das schweißt. Ätzende Leute, ich hasse diese Leute. Ich hasse vibrierende Dinge. Ganz kurz, eine Sache noch. Tatsächlich, weil es gibt ja so diesen sage ich mal, Jerry Seinfeld-esken Alltags situational wie sagen wir nicht? Das fällt mir das deutsche Wort nicht ein. Nee, auch das Englische nicht. Ach so. Aber das Indische. Wenn man Dinge beobachtet. Ja. Fuck. Ach, Beobachtungs. Nein, aber da gibt es ein englisches Wort, eine Art von Observational. Observational Comedy, sehr gut, vielen Dank. So, da gibt es ja dieses, ich hasse es, wie Leute ihre Sachen im Supermarkt auf das Fließband legen, scheiße. Wo ich mir immer dachte, kann man diesen Humor denn in den tatsächlichen Alltag übertragen, oder ist es wirklich nur was, was man losgelöst vom Alltag auf einer Stand-Up-Bühne erzählen kann? Ja, genau. Geht das nicht oder nicht? Zum Beispiel, ich falle auf einem ICE, und da ist es tatsächlich der Fall, dass die ICE irgendwie jetzt, wir legen jetzt bald in Köln an, in 20 Minuten oder so und jeder weiß, wann der Zug ankommt, weil es auf seinem Ticket steht, aber trotzdem stehen die Leute wirklich ohne Witz 25 Minuten, bevor der Zug ankommt, stehen auf und stellen sich an die Tür. So, und jetzt ist es natürlich eine Kettenreaktion. Sobald das einer macht, sehen alle anderen, oh, der läuft durch mit dem Kopf. Genau, scheiße, fuck, ich muss auch aufstehen, sonst stehe ich fest. Und das ist wichtig, ich gebe dieser ersten Person die Haupt und vollständige Schuld an dem, was dann passiert. Weil alle anderen Folgen und verstopfen da alles. Und ich habe mir meinen Wecker immer so gestellt, weil ich schlafe oder döse, dass er zehn Minuten, bevor wir ankommen, klingelt, so dass ich nochmal aufs Klo gehen kann und dann raus. Aber das geht nicht, weil die gesamten Gänge schon komplett verstopft sind, obwohl es nicht nötig ist. Und ich habe tatsächlich mal die Zeit gestoppt, wie viel Zeit man tatsächlich spart, wenn man ganz sofort aufsteht oder wenn man bis zum Ende sitzen bleibt und es ist maximal eine Minute, maximal, wahrscheinlich weniger. Mir geht es immer so, ich muss immer ganz früh darüber nachdenken, wie ich gleich aufstehen werde. Also wenn ich ganz viele Sachen habe und neben mir sitzt doch jemand, der aufstehen muss, wenn ich auch aufstehen will und rausgehen will, weil meine Station mal kommt,
dann geht es mir immer so, dass ich immer ganz früh anfange nachzudenken, was nehme ich jetzt zuerst gleich, wie gebe ich die Person zu erkennen, dass ich gleich aufstehen will und so. Sehr gut, absolut. Das ist vielleicht so ein Spleen, aber habe ich. Doch, geht mir absolut auch so und bei mir wird es tatsächlich noch dadurch bemüht, dass ich einen Rucksack habe, wo wahnsinnig viel drin ist. Da sind wirklich Kleider drin, weil ich nicht weiß, ob ich übernachte oder nicht. Ganz viele vibrierende Dinger. Ganz viele vibrierende Dinger, ein bisschen Kleingeld natürlich dabei. Die mitgehen lassen wäre auch super mal. Die portable fleischfressende Pflanze darf natürlich nicht fehlen. All das ist dabei und auch da muss ich Tetris-esk natürlich planen. Dinge, die oben sind, kann ich sofort ran. Wenn ich das jetzt rausnehme und dann die Wasserflasche nehme und das andere dann zuerst tue, brauche ich es noch oder nicht,
muss da wahnsinnig planen und habe eigentlich schon jeden Handgriff der ganzen Reise durchgeplant. Aber nochmal ganz kurz, ich würde gern zu dieser ersten Person, nicht zu allen, zu dieser ersten Person hingehen und würden sagen, so Freundchen, wir gucken jetzt mal gemeinsam auf die Uhr. So, es ist neun Uhr drei und Sie wissen doch, dass der Zug um neun Uhr dreissig anlegt. Sie stehen augenscheinlich, objektiv, siebenundzwanzig Minuten bevor der Zug ankommt, stehen Sie hier. Schauen Sie mal bitte jetzt auf Ihre Uhr und schauen Sie mal bitte jetzt auf Ihr Ticket und glauben Sie es nicht, dass es klüger ist, sitzen zu bleiben, weil wenn Sie aufstehen, stehen alle anderen Deppen auch auf, die keine Ahnung haben, und dann hat der Zug noch Verspätung zehn Minuten, dann stehen Sie insgesamt vierzig Minuten. Vierzig Minuten! Das machen Sie ja nicht. Vor allem dann denke ich mir, was denken sich die Leute dabei, wenn du zu dem Typen hingehst, während er sitzt und sagt, wenn Sie jetzt aufstehen, stehen Sie vierzig Minuten lang. Wird niemand auf der Welt, kein einziger Mensch, wird aufstehen, niemand, non, vielleicht sagt er einfach zu dir dann in diesem Moment, ja, ich würde jetzt gerne stehen, ich habe den ganzen Tag schon gesessen und dann guckst du in die Röhre. Nein, glaube ich nicht, glaube ich nicht, das sind Leute, das sind Leute, die sich verunsichern lassen, wenn der Ansager sagt, irgendwie, wir legen gleich in Köln an und dann stehen sie sofort auf und wollen nicht als Letzter rausgehen und bla bla blub. Aber sie raffen einfach nicht. Simple Arithmetik, simples Zählen von Minuten raffen sie einfach nicht. Und ich finde, das ist so ein Problem, das sich perfekt an einer einzigen Person festmachen lässt. Das ist kein irgendwie sozial kompliziertes Gefühl, es ist eine einzige Arschlochperson, die diese Lawine in Gang setzt. Und da dachte ich mir, könnte man da nicht mal zu dieser Person hingehen und das mit der bereden und so auf halb lustige, halb ernste Art mit ihr tatsächlich über dieses Problem reden, um es zu lösen. Weil ich bin lösungsorientiert. Und diese Person ist auch diese Person, die Pflanzen am Leben halten kann, weil es genau weiß, wann die Pflanzen nämlich gegossen werden müssen. Und das ist auch eine Person, die diese Dinger, bevor diese vibrierenden und blinkenden Dinger losgehen, schon das Essen wollen. Ja, genau, das sind alles dieselbe Person. Furchtbar. Und das sind auch Personen, die arbeiten wahrscheinlich bei irgendeiner Hotline für irgendein, ich sage jetzt mal, Komfortmöbel im weitesten Sinne, sitzen da an der Hotline und sind sehr genervt, einfach weil sie den ganzen Tag gestanden haben, weil sie bei jeder Situation immer schon 40 Minuten davor aufstehen. Das sind, die hat letzte Woche in der Anrufannahme gearbeitet und regt dich darüber auf, wenn sie einen Anruf angenommen hat. Das ist nur die Anrufannahme! Das ist so, wie wenn sich eine Müllabfuhrmännler darüber aufregen, wenn Leute den Müll rausstellen. Das ist absolute Arbeitsverweigerung. Das geht echt nicht. Aber was ich noch mal dazu sagen wollte zu letzter Woche, ich wollte dir noch mal in den Rücken fallen, das hatte ich schon mal angekündigt, privat, weil ich habe mir das noch mal angehört und ich dachte erst so, ja, das sind ganz schöne Arschlöcher, die haben ganz schön scheisse reagiert, aber es hat wahnsinnig genervt, deine Fahrgerei hat wahnsinnig genervt. Du hast irgendwann so richtig abstruse Fragen gestellt, die nie ein normaler Mensch, der nicht ausserhalb, der ausserhalb dieses Radiokosmos würde niemand diese Fragen stellen. Mit Meeresbiologe und so das. Moment, das sind im Moment jetzt noch leere Anschuldigungen. Kannst du da mal ein bisschen mehr Inhalt bringen? Nein, absolut nicht. Das möchte ich auch gar nicht. Ich möchte an dieser Oberfläche kratzen und dich versuchen zu verletzen. Ja, ich will mich ja verbessern. Ich will ja Kritik annehmen können. Was meinst du? Du hast sehr viele Fragen gestellt und... Ja, aber was soll ich denn machen? Soll ich irgendwie anfangen, Smalltalk zu machen? Es geht darum, einfach Dinge zu klären, Informationen zu erhalten und das macht man mit Fragen. Ja, das stimmt, aber es war halb acht abends und es waren irgendwie auch so Fragen, die... Wie du sofort switcht von Es ist mal schuld zu... Ja, ich habe jetzt gerade in diesem Moment... Deine Argumentation hat mich gecatcht und jetzt bin ich wieder anderer Meinung. Sehr gut, alles wieder auf Partei, die mir wunderbar weiter geht. Ich bin wie eine Fahne im Wind. So, das war jetzt ein Downer. War echt ein Downer jetzt eigentlich. Aber könnt ihr nicht mal, also ich weiß immer nicht, solche Leute, die da aufstehen, hören die Podcasts, kann man die erreichen, wenn ihr so ein Arschloch seid? Nee, glaub ich nicht. Dann schreibt doch mal eine Mail an zentrale-podcast-uvo.fail und meldet euch. Wir laden euch gerne in den Podcast ein, ihr könnt mitreden, vielleicht habt ihr ja gute Gründe, ein Arschloch zu sein. Ist ja okay, vielleicht fehlt mir nur die Hälfte der Informationen einfach, aber könnt ihr mir das erklären? Was ich glaube, wenn die vierzig eher aufstehen, dann haben die sich da vor die 20 Minuten Gedanken gemacht, wie sie aufstehen, wenn jemand neben denen sitzt, den sie wegscheuchen müssen, wie wir. Wir haben ja beide diesen Tick anscheinend, anscheinend haben es noch mehr Leute. Das heißt, die beschäftigen sich bestimmt ungefähr so 75 Prozent der Zeit damit, Gedanken zu machen. Doch bevor sie überhaupt losfahren. Genau, sich 75 Prozent beschäftigen, die sich mit dem Ausstiegsprozess. Das heißt, bevor sie losfahren, müssen sie sich schon Gedanken gemacht haben, wie sie ihren Rucksack packen, wie sie gleich aussteigen. Also wahnsinnig verkopfte Leute sind das anscheinend. Was ich auch tatsächlich hasse, sind Drängler. Leute, die drängeln so irgendwie, wenn man im Zug ... Du magst Drängler? Bin ich selber, ich bin Drängler. Ich bin überhaupt kein Drängler, weil ich finde, Drängeln ist komplett unrational einfach, weil dadurch nichts erreicht wird. Doch, Zeit. Also ich will mir ein... Nein, überhaupt nicht. Nein, aber angenommen ist eine folgende Situation. Eine Traube im Menschen bildet sich vor dem Einstieg in einen ICE, zum Beispiel nehmen wir jetzt mal irgendeinen Alltagsgegenstand in einen ICE, so und steigen ein. Und jeder weiß, es braucht eine gewisse Zeit, bis eine Person eingestiegen kann und dann steigt die nächste Person ein. Es bringt nichts zu drängeln, überhaupt nichts. Und du stehst da und schaust der Person, die gerade einsteigt, zu und hinter dir jemand drückt einfach und hinter dem steht niemand. Das stimmt, das weiss ich. Ich drehe mich einfach manchmal zu dem um und sage einfach, haben Sie eigentlich einen Schaden? Was erwarten Sie denn, dass jetzt passiert? Du bist privat wahnsinnig unfreundlich. Was erwarten Sie denn, dass jetzt passiert? Aber das ist einfach so ein, ich glaube, da ist der Körper Sklave des Geistes. Der Geist sagt, ich will da rein, ich will da rein. Und der Körper lässt sich so davon saugen und drängt einfach so rein. Mir geht es nur um Zeit. Nee, aber eben nicht. Wenn es wirklich schneller ginge, dann könnte man das ja argumentativ rationalisieren. Aber das ist ja nicht möglich. Wenn man tatsächlich sich darüber Gedanken macht, merkt man, es geht schneller, wenn man die Leute in Ruhe lässt, nicht drängelt, sondern einfach nacheinander die Leute reingehen lässt. Das war eine gute Lehre. Das war eine gute Lehre jetzt nochmal zum Schluss. Wir haben fast schon wieder eine Stunde geredet jetzt. Ja, fick dich einfach. Du bist nämlich einer von solchen Leuten, die einfach... Mir geht es um Zeit. Wenn ich was bei Leuten nicht mag, dann ist es Aufmerksamkeitsmangel. Wenn Leute, Leute sind ja nicht dumm. Ich glaube, wenn du Leuten einfach, also zum Beispiel, ganz kurzes Beispiel, reichst dich nochmal ganz kurz ab, habe ich schon 300.000 Mal in verschiedenen Podcasts gesagt. Was ich zum Beispiel überhaupt nicht leiden kann. Du hast noch andere Podcasts? Nein, was ich zum Beispiel überhaupt nicht leiden kann, ist, wenn Leute an der Supermarktkasse Gegenstände auf ihr Laufband legen. Und dann ist es einfach, gehört es für mich zum Usus, dass du einfach deine Gegenstände begleitest, dass wenn deine Gegenstände nach vorne fahren, du mitgehst, sodass du immer neben ihnen stehst. Das machen aber viele Leute nicht, die bleiben einfach stehen und ihre Gegenstände fahren nach vorne, sodass eine Lücke entsteht. Und dann haben die nämlich Leute, die sich um ihre Lebensmittel kümmern, haben nämlich dann auch so ein Sorgfalzproblem. Ich nehme die oft an der Hand, wenn da so ein gefrorenes Huhn liegt, nehme ich das an der Hand. Es gehört einfach mir, ich habe eine gewisse Verantwortung dafür. Und wenn die das aber nicht machen, fährt es weiter und ich, der hinter der Person steht, kann meine Sachen nicht aufladen, weil ich nicht an die Lücke dran komme, weil diese scheiß Person an dem steht. Und dann muss ich die mir so werfen und ich bin da wirklich ein Arschloch, muss ich ganz ehrlich zugeben. Ich mache das dann so ganz umständlich so, lege ich das dann so hin, als hätte ich enorme Schmerzen und als wäre das jetzt das furchtbarste der Welt, dass ich meinen Arm da an der Person vorbei muss, damit die Person überdeutlich merkt, oh, Entschuldigung, ich stehe im Weg. Aber da glaube ich zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt so wie bei einer Fahrschule so ein Diagramm von oben zeigt mit den verschiedenen Personen und dann verschiedene Szenarien anbietet, was soll die Person tun, das oder das, würden alle, 100% der Leute die richtige Antwort wählen. Es liegt nur daran, dass sie sich der Situation einfach nicht bewusst sind. Sie sind in der Lage, das Problem zu lösen, aber sie erkennen das Problem. Die wollen gegen den Strom schwimmen. Nein, eben nicht. Sie sind einfach nur dumm. Sie machen sich einfach keine Gedanken. Sie sind sich des Problems nicht bewusst, könnten es aber richtig lösen. Und das finde ich ärgerlich. Nicht, dass Leute zu dumm sind oder irgendwie sich nicht richtig verhalten können, sondern dass sie einfach unaufmerksam sind und einfach denken und einfach überhaupt nicht denken. Aber du wirst dann auch wahrscheinlich in anderen Augen dumm handeln. Ja, absolut. Wenn du dann mit deinem Kleingeldbecher da stehst an der Kasse und versuchst, mit ein Centstücken deinen scheiß Mango-Kack zu bezahlen, dann regnet sich die hinterher auch auf. Ja, aber dann sollen sie es mir zeigen durch Seufzen und Augenrollen. Augenrollen. Es gibt soziale Hinweise, die einem das zeigen, die sagen, du bist ein Depp. Änder dein Verhalten. Wie oft hast du mit den Augen gerollt heute im Laufe des Podcasts? Bestimmt 400 Umdrehungen. Ja. Mindestens. Mindestens. Das ist ordentlich Meter zurückgelegt. Ich bin schon ganz schwindelig. Ach ja, ich glaube, diese Folge war ein bisschen besser, oder? Jetzt erzähl du noch mal was. Ich habe jetzt so viel erzählt. Jetzt hau du noch mal Dinge, die wichtig erscheinen, aber nicht wichtig sind, raus. Ach so, ich hätte nicht mehr so viel. Ich hätte noch, ich hätte viele Dinge aufsehen können, die unwichtig scheinen, aber wahnsinnig wichtig sind. Können wir ja nächste Woche machen. Ja, aber irgendwie drehen wir uns auch in so einem Kreis um Dinge. Das stimmt, wir reden immer nur über Dinge. Ja, wahnsinnig scheiße. Ich habe aufgeschrieben, Sandwichmaker scheint wichtig, gut, scheint bei vielen nicht wichtig, bei mir schon. Ich dachte, Sandwich mache ich wahnsinnig oft, deswegen brauche ich einen Sandwich Maker. Wahnsinnig überflüssig, weil auch lange, es dauert total lange, es dauert unfassbar lange damit, gefühlt. Und vor allem das Putzen ist ja das Schlimme. Aber da muss man einfach irgendwann die Entscheidung treffen. Und sobald man die Entscheidung trifft, ist sein Leben einfach besser. Man lässt es dreckiger. Man lässt es einfach sein. Genau.
Man lässt die Kruste Kruste sein, das schimmelt nicht, das ist steinhart, da kann der Schimmel sich nicht reindrücken, der ist zu dick, da passiert nichts.
Es ist vielleicht unhygienisch und sieht scheisse aus, aber vor allem muss man ja ganz ehrlich zugeben, am Sandwich, die aus Sandwich-Megern kommen, ist immer das am Beste, diese Kruste von vergammelten vier Wochen alten Käse, der dann auch hängt, aber gereift ist und kross ist, das ist einfach das Beste. Und sobald man das tatsächlich sich bewusst macht und nicht so ein perverses Geheimnis des Unterbewusstseins belässt, sondern das einfach akzeptiert als solches, dann kann man auch mehr Spaß haben in seinem Leben und mit einem Sandwich-Maker. Das stimmt, ich glaube,, mehr Dinge einem egal sind, umso wichtiger, umso einfacher ist das Leben zu leben.
Ja, nicht egal. Man muss sie sich bewusst machen und sie dann aktiv ignorieren.
Aktiv, proaktiv ein Egalsein entwickeln muss man. Genau, das ist was anderes, als wenn man sie einfach nicht bemerkt. Man muss sie bemerken und dann aktiv sich dazu entscheiden, dass sie keine Rolle spielen, dass sie nicht relevant sind.
Dann habe ich noch aufgeschrieben Handyhülle. Handyhülle finde ich mega unwichtig. Also wenn ich ein Handy fallen lasse, dann richtig. Dann bin ich voller Wucht. Dann auch keine Scheiss, dann fällt auch genau mit dem Display auf ein Stein, der im Boden rausguckt. Und da ist jede scheiss Hülle egal. Da kann es auch 50 Meter Luftpolsterfolie sein, die da irgendwie mein Handy schützt. Es wird trotzdem kaputt gehen. Ja, vor allem die Hülle schützt ja sowieso nur die Ecken, die sowieso einiges aushalten. Ja, die sind eh unwichtig. Die können auch, die können einfach ein bisschen kratzig sein. Ja, ich hatte tatsächlich in meinem Leben noch nie eine Handyhülle. Noch nie. Ne, ich noch ein paar Mal. So Hello Kitty, so ein bisschen strumpfartig. Oh Gott, du hattest echt so einen Strumpf. Die waren mal echt in Mode. Mittlerweile sind es eher diese Hartgummi-Teile, die man drum rödelt. Aber diese Strümpfe waren mal echt. Aber daran kann man ja, glaube ich, echt sehr schön die Entwicklung des Smartphones sehen. Früher der Strumpf, das Display verschwindet komplett, es gerät komplett in die Unnutzbarkeit. Wohingegen jetzt ist das Smartphone ja konstant in Benutzung und da muss das
Display frei sein. Wohingegen früher hat man es
aktiv und dann wieder nicht benutzt, wohingegen
jetzt benutzt man es durchgehend.
Mittlerweile haben viele diese Panzerhüllen,
diese Hüllen, wo man das dann runterfallen lässt und es bleibt
heil, sagen die Leute. Und dann habe ich
mal bei zehn Leuten versucht, das Handy
zu nehmen und zu sagen, ja gut,
dann lasse ich es jetzt fallen und habe in den
Augen versucht zu lesen, ob die Angst haben oder nicht. Ob sie wirklich ihrer Hülle vertrauen oder nicht. Und ohne Scheiss, alle haben der Hülle nicht vertraut. Das heißt, die haben diese dicke Panzerhülle, um allen zu zeigen, ja, ich habe eine monstergeile Hülle und ich kann mein Handy von der Zugspitze werfen, das wird noch leben. Und keiner von denen vertraut seiner Hülle aber aktiv. Und dann finde ich, das wäre ein Fehlkauf dann. Wow, krass, Bogen geschlagen. Das stimmt, aber das sind solche Käufe, die ich eigentlich nicht mag. Man muss akzeptieren, wenn mein Handy runterfällt, geht es sowieso kaputt. Und das ist auch gut so. Das ist nicht gut so, aber man muss proaktiv eine Egalhaltung entwickeln. Ich kann auch noch mal ein paar Sachen vorlesen, müssen wir jetzt gar nicht näher darauf eingehen, die ich mir vorgeschrieben habe. Dinge, die wichtig erscheinen, aber gar nicht richtig sind, Kohlensäure. Ist für mich so ein Ding komplett überbewertet, brauche ich eigentlich nicht. Habe ich noch geschrieben, Inflation. Aber bei Kohlensäure habe ich mich gefragt, wie sind Leute auf die Idee gekommen jemals? Total. Ja, vor allem Kohlensäure ist ja eigentlich was total Craziges. Das ist irgendwie Säure. Ja. Also was total, was überhaupt nicht auf die Idee gekommen jemals. Total. Ja, vor allem, Kohlensäure ist ja eigentlich was total Craziges, das ist irgendwie Säure. Ja. Also was total, wo man überhaupt nicht auf die Idee kommen würde, verbinden wir das noch einfach mal random mit Lebensmitteln. Und trinken das dann auch noch? Ja, aber vor allem... Wer war der Erste, der das getrunken hat? Das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Und vor allem, wie konnte sich das durchsetzen? Weil die Menschen trinken seit Millionen Jahren Dinge, die einfach irgendwie nicht kohlensäure belastet sind, in dem absoluten Essenz der menschlichen Existenz, dem Aufnehmen von Flüssigkeit, dass man das noch verändern kann, ist doch wirklich ein Beweis für die Innovationskraft des Menschen. Und würde man das heute machen, würden Sie sagen, nein, das hatten wir früher nicht, damals, dann geht die Pegida wieder auf die Strasse, wollen wir nicht hier, früher brauchen wir auch nicht. Wir hassen Kohlensäure. Wir hassen raus mit der Kohlensäure, ausser sie arbeitet. Kohlensäure nimmt uns Arbeitsplätze weg. Genau, sowas, ja, aber das ist schon bemerkenswert, dass man wirklich da die Konsistenz oder wie man es halt nennen soll, die Beschaffenheit von Flüssigkeit verändert. Wow, da ziehe ich echt meinen Hut. Ja, hast du noch mehr? Ziehe ich echt meinen Hut, also wirklich Kohlenzäure. Inflation. Ist unwichtig? Ist völlig unwichtig. Ja, okay, merkt man als Verbraucher nicht. Inflation ist immer so ein Angstthema, so ein provokantes Thema, eigentlich egal. Dinge, die wichtig erscheinen, aber gar nicht wichtig sind, Kabeltrommel. Glaube ich, ist offensichtlich, glaube ich, ist ein No-Brainer, hat jeder instinktiv auf seine... Jeder hat instinktiv genickt, Deutschland hat instinktiv genickt. Ja, absolut. Kabeltrommeln, absolut überbewertet. Braucht man so gut wie nie. Braucht niemand. Und wenn man sie braucht, dann verheddert sich alles. Und eigentlich kann man das nicht mehr so gut. Und die kann man auch nie wieder aufrollen. Ich glaube, die kann man einfach nicht wieder benutzen. Also ich kann es nicht als Mensch. Furchtbar. Generell, wir sollten mal eine Folge machen zu Dingen, die man aufrollt. Ich glaube, aufrollen ist an sich eine superoptimale Aufrunde. Jojo wäre der König der Folge dann wahrscheinlich. Aber auch so irgendwie so Fadenknäuel oder sowas. Ich kriege nie wieder so aufgerollt, wie sie waren. Keine Chance. Wieso hast du Fadenknäuel? Hast du ein Problem im Alltagsproblem, dass du Fadenknäuel nicht wieder aufruhren kannst? Das ist mir noch nie ein bewusstes Problem gewesen. Eben, bewusst machen und dann aktiv ignorieren. Aktiv ignorieren. Und tatsächlich noch eine Sache, vielleicht als Rausschmeisser, oder ich weiß nicht, wie dein Luststand noch steht. Ich hätte von Minute eins keinen Bock mehr gehabt. Dinge, die wichtig erscheinen, aber gar nicht wichtig sind, das Ausland.
Generell Ausland.
Eigentlich kann man komplett drauf verzichten. Boah, Florentin, das kann man glaube ich nicht sagen.
Nein, aber jetzt nicht im Sinne von Ausländer oder so, oder Deutschland ist das beste Land der Welt oder so, aber eigentlich muss man nicht verreisen.
Oder meinst du dem, ach so, nee, das finde ich scheisse.
Ich finde den Begriff Ausland, um mal so ein Weltbürgertum hier zu verbreiten.
Ja, bitte.
Der Begriff Ausland ist unwichtig. Welcher Begriff wäre besser? Wir sind alle Erdenbürger. Oh Gott. Auch wahnsinnig scheiße. Ich mache mich wieder wahnsinnig gut. Andersland. Ja, genau. Westerland vielleicht. Auswärts, ein bisschen weiter weg vielleicht. Ein bisschen weiter weg Land. Weg Land. Ja, ein bisschen weiter weg und kulturell anders. Land von erhöhter Entfernung. Vielleicht sollte man doch Ausland sagen. Nein, aber ich sehe sehr oft, ich bin ja viel auf Tinder unterwegs. Und was man da im Vorhang sieht. Ach ja, wie läuft es eigentlich nicht? Level Up? Nee, leider nicht. Ich bin immer noch im Startgebiet. Ich kriege die Quest noch nicht. Nee, das ist schwierig. Was man da vor allem sieht, da wollen die Leute ja angeben. Die wollen angeben damit, was sie schon erlebt haben. Und wenn sie nicht gut aussehen, müssen sie halt andere Sachen. Ich zum Beispiel gebe damit an, dass ich im Fernsehen arbeite. Ich habe zum Beispiel ein Bild von mir, wie ich mit der Maus, von Sendung mit der Maus, ein Foto mache. Da sehen die Leute, oh, der arbeitet im Fernsehen. Lustig, aber gleich professionell interessant. Aber manche werden sagen, ich finde den Elefanten süsser. Und dann werden sie nach links freuen. Aber das ist schon mal ein Gesprächsthema, das ist ein Icebreaker, da kann man sie direkt anschreiben und sagen, nee, ich finde den Elefanten besser und hat sofort ein interessantes Thema. Und die meisten Leute, die weder gut aussehen noch in den Medien arbeiten, geben damit an, dass sie schon mal im Ausland waren. Und dann sieht man sie auf einem Berg oder im Meer oder von der Kirche, wo man einfach denkt, es ist scheißegal, es ist keine Leistung, ins Ausland zu fahren. Und im Grunde ist das Ausland auch in den meisten Fällen nicht so gut wie hier, muss man auch mal sagen. Die Pizza haben wir hier auch, ja, wir haben auch hier schöne Kirchen, wir haben auch hier hohe Berge. Wir haben auch die hohen Gebäude. Wer braucht das denn überhaupt? Ich glaube, ins Ausland fahren lebt einzig und allein von der Vorstellung, ich bin Weltbürger, ich bin Globetrotter. Aber wenn man das mal rein objektiv betrachtet, kommt man unweigerlich zu der Entscheidung, dass man sagt, eigentlich braucht es das nicht. Ich habe noch einen Fehlkauf, fällt mir gerade auf. Ja, hau raus. Adventskalender, Adventskalender habe ich mir einen besorgt. Oh, gut, dass du mich erinnerst, ich habe meine Tüche noch einen öffnen. Ja, genau deswegen ja, ich vergesse es immer, es ist ein unfassbarer Fehlkauf. Ja, aber das ist doch ein total geiles Gefühl, wenn du es vergisst. Nein, es schmeckt erst mal schmeckt die Schokolade. Also wenn man die ausserhalb des Adventskalenders essen würde, würde man die scheisse finden. Nummer eins. Ich habe sogar zwei Türchen vergessen. Fünf, sieben und sechze. Ich habe, ich bin noch bei drei, glaube ich. Ich lebe in der Vergangenheit. Was? Ja, es geht mir so auf den Sack, dass der dir vorschreibt, dass du morgens was essen musst. Oder so tagsüber, also boah. Ja, es kommt natürlich auch ein bisschen auf den Adventskalender an, den man hat. Ich habe ja einen... Das ist heisslich. Ich habe einen Big Ben von After Eight. Wow. Der Big Ben-Turm. Und da sind immer so kleine After Eight-Pralinen drin. Ich bin ein großer Fan vom Pfefferminz. Und für mich ist das genau richtig. So ein kleiner Snack. Finde ich gut. Also muss ich dir erneut W-Ben-Widersprechen. Adventskalender steht für mich sogar auf der Top 5 des Jahres. Aber da kommen wir ja nicht hierzu. Das machen wir nächste Folge. Top 5 machen wir glaube ich nicht. Top 6, Top 5 ist glaube ich
ein Copyright drauf. Wir nehmen ja immer
dienstags auf und nächster Dienstag ist ja
tatsächlich der 23.
Wollen wir da aufnehmen oder ist es für die
Family Time? Ne, ne, können wir gerne aufnehmen.
Mir ist es völlig egal. Weihnachten ist mir egal.
Ich bin diese Daten. Ach Gott.
Ja, okay, dann haben wir noch die Weihnachtsfolge.
Nächstes Jahr können wir dann alles genau zu Weihnachten besprechen.
Was wir uns erhoffen, was wir verraten. Ich habe noch einen Fehlkauf vergessen. Hau raus! Haustiere. Ich habe schon mal Fische, ich habe damals mal ein Aquarium gehabt. Aber das passt so gut in das Bild, das ich von dir habe, dass du so einen spontanen Impulsivkauf eine Schildkröte. Dann merkst du einfach innerhalb von fünf Sekunden, das ist der dümmste Einkauf der Welt. Aber man kann sie jetzt nicht zurückbringen, weil man hat dem Ladentypen so gesagt, ja, ich will unbedingt Verantwortung übernehmen, lernen und so. Und ich hätte mal Fische, dann haben die sich irgendwann selbst gefressen, weil ich nichts zu sich machen habe. Also sich selbst aufgefressen, oder was? Aber dann wurde es wieder spannend, weil dann haben die sich selber gefressen und am Ende der Stärkste überlebt. Cool, einfach ein cooles Justalexperiment, was man machen sollte. Geht so. Ja, nee, sollte man nicht machen. Und dann hatte ich auch mal Wellensittiche, aber die sind halt nur cool, wenn man sich davor so lange um die kümmert, bis man die freilassen kann und die wieder zurückkommen und auf deiner Hand landen und so, dann sind die cool, aber bis dahin muss man sich halt lange um die kümmern. Und das war mir immer zu blöd, weil die bis dahin halt nichts konnten. Die können halt gucken und nerven und kacken. Kann man ja kombinieren, Fehlkäufe, Haustiere und Pflanzen. Ich hatte mal einen Bonsai-Baum. Du setzt gerade meine Wellensittiche gleich mit einem Bonsai-Baum. Ja, auch um den muss man sich kümmern, weil man denkt ja immer, ja, die sind halt irgendwie abgefahrene radioaktive Pflanzen aus Japan, die halt einfach ein bisschen kleiner sind. Bonsai-Bäume sind voll anspruchsvoll. Das sind richtige Dieven. Ja, vor allem die haben ja normale Blätter, aber man muss die Blätter so zuschneiden, dass die klein sind. Und irgendwann denken die sich, ja gut, alter, leck mich, dann habe ich halt jetzt nur noch kleine Blätter, wenn du mir die eh immer abschneidest. Und dann sehen die irgendwann aus wie ein kleiner Baum. Aber da muss man wirklich viel Arbeit investieren, das war es mir nicht wert. Am Ende hatte ich einen normalen Baum in meinem Zimmer. Eine riesengroß gewachsene Eiche. Ist aus deinem Fenster rausgeworfen, wo dann wieder Leute angerufen haben, ja, mir ist aufgefallen, es wächst ein Baum aus ihrem Fenster raus und ich habe ihre Handynummer, mein Sohn hat ihre Handynummer rausgefahren. Ja genau, die Jugendbahnen besprühen ihn schon. Die Jugendbahnen besprühen den Baum schon. Stefan. Es war am Ende doch ganz witzig.
Ja, in der zweite Folge, wie immer, könnt ihr uns
Kommentare schreiben und was auch immer auf unserer
Facebook-Seite, das Podcast. Ja, aber bitte mal nette Kommentare.
Abonniert uns auf iTunes, dann
verpasst ihr auch keine weitere Folge mehr und
gebt uns auf iTunes Sterne in Höhe von
bis zwei bis drei. Ja, sagt der, der uns zwei Sterne
gegeben hat. Es gibt einen, der zwei Sterne gegeben hat.
Du warst das. Nein.
Klar warst du das. Auf jeden Fall. Na gut, ich fand die erste Folge nicht so gut. Muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Da geht noch mehr. Klar geht da noch mehr. Aber sag doch mal was Nettes über mich. Also ich finde... Florentin könnte gerne mal was Blödes sagen. Vieles von dem, was du in der ersten Folge richtig gemacht hast, hast du jetzt besser gemacht. Du warst sehr lustig, sehr entspannt, spontan, mir gut gefallen, du hast dich vorbereitet, nicht optimal, muss man sagen, unterbesschnittlich. Nee, gar nicht. Ich habe mich fünf Minuten vor... Aber auch das hat völlig gereicht das hat ja gereicht ich habe ja gelernt von dir dass man sich nicht über vorbereiten soll und nicht alle häkchen im hausaufgabenheft haben muss im gegenteil gut ich passe auf ich habe ja alles aufgeschrieben was ich hoffe ihr konntet viel viel von stefan lernen und vor allem dass man von mir lernen kann das ist die wichtigste lektion anssonsten wünsche ich euch noch frohe Weihnachten, frohe Weihnachtsvorbereitungen.
Frohe Weihnachten, nee, wir sind ja nochmal da nächste Woche.
Ja, aber viel Spaß mit dem Einkaufen und so.
Ja, bis dahin, schön bei Amazon bestellen, ne, die sind gut.
Bis dann, macht's gut. Tschüss.
Ciao.